so generally robin hood has been on my
radar for a long time because i cover
fintech at forbes and it's
really one of the most important
companies in fintech and they just get a
lot of buzz because of the nature of the
app it's a consumer-facing app it's easy
to use
and it's growing really quickly so the
founders are
vlad tenev and beiju bot and
they met in 2005 at stanford they were
in a
physics research program together over
the summer after
college they both worked in finance they
had a hedge fund
they sold software to high frequency
traders
but then after the financial crisis
after occupy wall street
the way this story goes and the way they
tell it is that
they had friends who said you know you
guys are part of the problem
um in terms of inequality and you know
income distribution and so they said
well
we're going to start this company we're
going to make an app to
democratize finance that's where they
got the idea to to create an app where
you can trade stocks for free
a market maker is someone who executes
trades
the way that robinhood makes money is
that these market makers
are paying them they're paying them it's
called payment for order flow
when they receive an order from a robin
hood user
let's say to buy stock at a hundred
dollars so this robinhood user has
agreed to buy a stock for a hundred
dollars
the market maker because it has because
he or she has access to a lot of
inventory
can buy the stock for a little bit lower
so
let's say they bought it for 99.90
so the market maker is actually only
paying
99.90 for that stock even though the
robin hood user
agreed to pay a hundred dollars and so
that ten cent difference
is what the market maker pockets so
that's called the spread
and they're pocketing that and if you do
it you know a lot of times it adds up to
a lot of money
and so that's how the market makers make
money so they
pay robin hood pretty handsomely for the
right to
execute these trades because every time
they're executing trades they're making
a little bit of money
so they're kind of giving them these
payments so every quarter
you can see it because robin hood has to
disclose it every quarter they're paying
robin hood like in q2 is 180 million
dollars in q1 it was
91 million dollars so since the red
since
these orders are so lucrative for the
market makers they're willing to pay
robin hood and other brokers like
e-trade td ameritrade they're willing to
pay them a lot of money for them
i think what is surprising is that it's
basically just how lucrative this has
become
and how much money they're able to make
off it so
there's definitely a lot of tension
between
the you know robin hood's very often um
stated mission of democratizing finance
and the way it makes money and its
business model of
receiving very large payments from these
very large trading firms
um who yeah are some of the
the more profitable outfits um and who
uh you know are are pretty shrewd in
terms of
um in terms of the way they they operate
more recently
there was this very tragic story of a
user his name
was alexander kearns a 20 year old
university of nebraska student who was
using robin hood and
very sadly and tragically took his own
life in a note that he left
um he said he mentioned robin hood and
he said
you know how could i have been given all
this leverage essentially what
we understand our understanding of what
he did he did a very complex
um options trade on robin hood and he
mistakenly thought that he had lost 730
000 after investing just maybe ten or
fifteen thousand dollars
we wrote an article me um um and my two
colleagues
um sergey klebnikov and antoine gara um
wrote about it and it was the highest
traffic forbes article um in history
got almost 18 million views it just
brought to light the um the
kind of worst case things that can
happen when someone
either has access to a lot of leverage
or misunderstands what's happening with
their money
one thing going into the story that was
surprising to me was that
even though they've had these stumbles
they just keep growing they've now
gotten to this level of awareness
and that it's just propelling them
forward and that is going to be really
hard for competitors to touch
you